life in prison for throwing a glitter
bomb wait
what i thought you said this was legal
no mark rober is probably not going to
jail but two florida women have been
charged with felony offenses for
allegedly throwing a glitter bomb and a
man inside an apartment complex their
arrest made headlines with some
announcing that they faced life in
prison
for a glitter bomb now well it's
theoretically possible that they could
face that kind of a sentence they
probably won't face anything like that
but their actions do go well beyond
putting some glitter in an envelope and
surprising some porch pirates so they do
face potential heavy jail time and all
of this has twitter wondering just what
are the legal implications of attacking
people with glitter is it illegal to
send someone a box of glitter through
the mail can you deal with a would-be
thief by booby trapping a package just
how much money does hobby lobby make in
glitter sales and how do we stop mark
rober today we're talking everything
glitter bombs
glitter bombs became popular about 10
years ago when some gay rights activists
started throwing glitter bombs in the
faces of politicians who opposed gay
marriage some famous people have since
been on the receiving end of a glitter
bomb for example in 2012 a boulder
student was arrested for glitter bombing
mitt romney at a colorado campaign event
prosecutors originally charged peter
smith with throwing a missile at romney
but he pleaded guilty to disturbing the
peace a lesser charge here while the
glitter didn't make much of a visual
impact if you throw something at a
politician you should probably expect
the secret service to tackle you lindsay
lohan was on the receiving end of a
glitter bomb while she was on her way to
court as you can see the use of the
glitter looked more like rice or
confetti and i guess the message was
congratulations on your jail time
glitter bombing celebrities and
politicians was all the rage for a
couple of years in the early aughts this
being america the glitter bomb fat
encouraged a few enterprising souls to
turn glitter bombing into a business
websites popped up all over the place
allowing you to send a glitter bomb
through the mail just pay 39.99 enter an
address and presto you've just pranked
someone so at first glance this all just
seems like harmless fun glitter is a
pain in the ass to clean up but beyond
that what's the harm amazon even sells
something called unicorn snot which is
described as quote biodegradable
holographic body glitter gel for body
face and hair so it's safe to say the
glitter by itself is annoying but
probably not dangerous but when we
consider whether any of this is criminal
it depends on what you do with it and
why people have lots of different
motivations for sending a glitter bomb
they may want to do it as a prank a joke
or even for revenge but in some cases
glitter can lead to serious criminal
charges it is alleged that the two
florida women in question caitlyn
o'donovan and sarah franks went to jacob
collins apartment at 3 o'clock in the
morning to argue with him about
something
we don't know what the argument was
about but while he stood on the balcony
the two women threw a container of
glitter at him hitting his head and
torso frank's then scaled a fence broke
into colin's apartment and threw more
glitter at colin when colin was covered
in glitter franks let o'donovan into the
apartment and she threw yet more
containers of glitter had colin frank's
then kicked a window until it broke and
then left the apartment the smoky gun
tracked down the arrest affidavits which
revealed that colin had called the
police and gave them a description of
their car police found the car which was
unsurprisingly covered in glitter
o'donovan and franks were charged with
felony burglary and assault and battery
frank's got an additional charge for
criminal mischief so while the story is
definitely more than just throwing
glitter at someone the crux of the
argument here is that they went to
someone's apartment and threw glitter at
them and so to understand what's going
on here we have to talk about the law of
assault and battery assault and battery
are criminal charges as well as civil
torts in the criminal context a person
commits battery if they intentionally
cause a harmful or offensive contact
with another person in many
jurisdictions an assault is an attempt
to commit battery in other words any
intentional act that causes another
person to fear that he or she is about
to suffer physical harm would be
considered assault while the battery
requires actual physical conduct by the
person or an extension of that person
the police report here says that the two
women hit colin with a flying object
multiple jars of glitter if these facts
are true that's potentially battery and
here the alleged facts suggest that
these acts were intentional since the
women apparently rolled up on collin's
apartment reared with several containers
of glitter and then you know covered his
apartment and his person with glitter it
might be hard for them to claim that
they were just headed to his house in
the middle of the night for an evening
of hardcore crafting and the police
charged both women with burglary which
in florida is defined as entering a
dwelling a structure or conveyance with
the intent to commit a defense therein
okay so it's not that surprising that
under these facts you can be in big
trouble for breaking and entering into
someone's house assaulting them with
glitter and breaking a window still
though this is not the kind of situation
where you would expect the perpetrators
or the alleged perpetrators to be facing
life in prison and there's definitely a
conversation to be had here about the
carceral state that we tend to only
ratchet the penalties for crimes up and
not down and we tend to over-incarcerate
people this is a large and systemic
issue that we face but the thing that i
want to talk about today is a little
more light-hearted what about all of
these other glitter attacks how could
they possibly be legal well to answer
that question let's consider the legal
implications of mark rober's holiday
package glitter bombs because every
december mark rober spends christmas
cheer by getting back at package thieves
honestly these are some of my favorite
videos of the year robert engineers a
glitter bomb inside of a box that looks
like an ordinary package once the porch
thief picks up the package and opens the
box it detonates a glorious spray of
glitter and aerosolized farts this is
nasa engineering at its finest
but so far none of these thieves have
sued rover nor has he been arrested
doesn't his act intentionally planting a
device that explodes glitter in
someone's face meet the traditional
definition of battery well the answer
might surprise you and to dig into this
let's look at the texas law since that's
where mark robert's original video took
place and we just talked about assault
when someone apprehends immediate bodily
injury or contact and battery refers to
the actual bodily contact whether it's
harmful or offensive and the texas
statutes tend to mirror the generalized
definition of assault and battery under
texas law intentionally or knowingly
causing physical contact with another
person when that person should know or
reasonably believe that the other will
regard the contact as offensive or
provocative is a misdemeanor crime
unless committed against a public
servant so as with most things we have
to start with intent because intent is
almost always a requirement of the crime
and here did robert knowingly cause
physical contact with another person
well
seems like it he planted a device that
he knew would cause glitter particles to
hit or almost hit another person or
their property and while these glitter
bombs haven't caused any physical injury
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
being covered in glitter and fart spray
is offensive or at least provocative and
if you think it's wrong for a thief to
have any human rights whatsoever and to
be able to complain about anything well
you should probably watch my video on
the shotgun booby trap case which is
based on the very famous case of catko
vs briny in that case the briny family
owned a boarded-up farmhouse in iowa
marvin catco and his accomplice broke
into the building and stole old bottles
and fruit jars the brinys posted no
trespassing signs but the burglaries
continued that's when edward briny
decided to take matters into his own
hands and he mounted a 20-gauge
spring-loaded shotgun in a farmhouse and
rigged it to fire when a bedroom door
was opened the bedroom window was also
covered with steel
in 1967 catko and his accomplice broke
into the farmhouse and this time katco
went into the bedroom tripping the
trigger wire the gun fired into his
right leg blowing away most of his tibia
and while katco was convicted of
burglary after serving his time he sued
the briny family for assault and battery
in 1971 the iowa supreme court decided
the case and the supreme court found
that the rule of law to be applied was
this one may use reasonable force to
protect property but may not use a means
of force that will take you in life or
inflict great bodily harm the fact that
a trespasser may be acting in violation
of the law would not change the rule and
the only time the setting of a spring
gun is justified is if a trespasser is
committing a felony of violence or one
punishable by death or where a
trespasser is endangering human life by
his act and so a jury awarded catco 20
thousand dollars for actual damages plus
another ten thousand dollars in punitive
damages remember this was the 1960s so
that was quite a lot of money so it's
probably an open and shut case against
mark grober right well probably wrong
that's because unlike a shotgun booby
trap a glitter bomb package isn't going
to kill or seriously injure anyone under
texas law a person who is accused of
committing a battery can avoid liability
if the act in question was committed in
defense of their property if the act was
reasonable and not lethal robber's
glitter bomb is not at all like a
shotgun mounted to a bed set to kill an
intruder under texas self-defense law
you're not permitted to use deadly force
to protect your property however you can
use non-lethal and reasonable force to
protect your property from thieves and
trespassers so it's a good thing the
glitter bomb is just glitter and fart
spray because if he sprayed the person
with acid or bleach or rigged a package
to fire a weapon explode or release a
pit of vipers that probably would not be
justified it would also be a lot less
entertaining to watch on youtube one
might make an analogy to anti-climb
paint anti-climate paint is slippery and
prevents someone from climbing wall now
i'm only covering one of the many
potential defenses for mark rover here
there i think a bunch of others as well
but the main thing is that mark didn't
climb into some innocent person's house
break in and start throwing glitter and
fart spray in the eyes of the law mark
rober is not a criminal at least about
that
[Music]
if only we could talk to mark robert to
find out what he was thinking okay you
gotta help me out here you gotta clear
my name who else is gonna glitter bomb
these thieves mark i told you not to use
the snakes
all right the the man himself mark rober
uh thanks so much for uh for joining
today good to be here let's get to the
bottom of this out of curiosity at this
point how much glitter and far spray do
you think you've gone through
like in like what metric like by by
pounds or by like number of boxes well i
mean uh you know you're a nasa engineer
so uh you know kilograms probably more
than pounds we gotta stick with freedom
unit
we're talking probably like 44 pounds of
glitter so that's like 20 kilograms give
or take of uh don't quote me on that ish
uh kilograms of glitter and i would say
probably we've gotten like 50 boxes
stolen or something wow at this point
and i know that you've gotten law
enforcement involved both in the porch
thieves and on tracking down some
honest-to-goodness scammers who are
taking advantage of uh you know
sometimes the elderly
has anything come from that uh
coordination with law enforcement so
we've literally had like
the department of justice like fbi
homeland security scotland yard inner
pool like all of them at some point in
some capacity have reached out um
including like i think it was like
microsoft's fraud team like companies as
well we will just give them our
information we're just like here you go
do with it what you want they generally
don't follow back with us and and say
what happened for whatever reason it's
not necessarily two-way street if we're
looking for like with like local
jurisdictions like this year
we're gonna work with san francisco pd
and and kind of
tackle the car uh people smashing and
grabbing uh cars and like stuff from
cars
so if we're working more like that then
then there's more back and forth but
otherwise uh we just kind of just give
them all the data and let them do with
what they will they have told us they
like what we're doing a because it's
like we do stuff technically that they
just want for don't have the resources
or abilities to do in their department
but b we can get away with stuff that
they can't do because we're like private
citizens i guess but somehow they could
use that information so it's like in
certain cases they were like no we love
what you're doing
please keep doing it for whatever reason
they're either legally or constrained
from a resource standpoint can't do it
so
they love when we feed them whatever we
get yeah well i mean that's that's a
great example uh
you know the police are bound by the
constitution uh
yeah theoretically theoretically they
should be bound by the constitution and
you know you get people saying oh that
infringes on my first amendment rights
when it doesn't actually involve the
government and the first amendment
doesn't apply to anything but the
government you are a private citizen so
there are there are rules that um define
what the government can do with
information that's created by private
citizens mark i noticed that a lot of
the people in your videos have blurred
faces uh is there a particular reason
why why you do that uh we might as well
just state it on your channel i put this
in description sometimes but basically
if someone doesn't sign a release i
don't their their face is then blurred
and uh i don't want to ruin anyone's
life over like a stupid
decision to like steal a package so by
default faces are blurred if you see a
face that's not blurred that's because
they signed a release and we went back
later and said hey uh will you sign a
release so i could put this in a dumb
video and uh and they've signed it are
you able to to prevent future uh package
thieves it's kind of a case-by-case
basis there's one two years ago these
two college students took it and uh
uh they were hilarious i didn't end up
turning their footage of the police or
anything but then discovery channel
we're doing something so they discovered
channel tracked them down and then i
interviewed them and i asked them like
so have you guys stolen any packages
since and they're like oh man i got in
so much trouble for my mom and my
grandma and then they're like you know
someone else a package came to their
house
accidentally just shipped to the wrong
address and he's like i freaking
personally walked that thing to georgia
where you know where where it actually
was supposed to deliver to because it's
like i didn't want anything to do with
this he's like i was gonna go through
hell or high water to make sure it got
to the right person so i was like oh
well my job is done here you know i
think they learned their lesson well uh
mark if if batman had a youtube channel
i think he would aspire to to do exactly
what you're doing um i think you're
doing really good work uh my final
question for you is
if mark rober found himself in jail
how would he engineer his way out of
imprisonment
man that's i mean what kind of jail is
it i got to know like what the
weaknesses are right and
usually i think those things come down
to a little bit of like combination of
social engineering you kind of got to
observe knowing the guards go on rest
make friends with the guard you know
depends on how long the jail change was
because also i'm not going to like break
out if that gives me like 20 more years
so you got to balance it all
but uh yeah but let's say you're you're
wrongfully imprisoned for life you are a
completely innocent man
but you have no hope of parole and
you're in you're in alcatraz how does
mark robert mark robert his way out of
alcatraz
yeah i'm going to el chapo baby i'm
digging a tunnel i'll invent a machine
that's like the fastest digging tunnel
machine and that's how i'm getting out i
think i'm calling it right now maybe
there's a collaboration with colin furs
and uh and digging his tunnel digging
the tunnel out of uh of jail good point
i feel like i'm mowing collins grass
here on this one all right well if i get
one caught phone call from jail you know
who it's going to now sorry mom i'm
calling colin oh
you've got a lot of tidying up to do
here first you've got a lot of tidying
up all right well thanks for the call
and by the way thanks for uh
being a lawyer and uh you're making me
sleep a little bit better at night
sometimes it's a little sketchy with
these things so knowing a lawyer of your
caliber has looked at this and and
cleared my name
uh means i can rest a little easier and
there's a higher probability we'll do
glitter bomb 5.0 and six and seven and
who knows where i'll be at when i get
the glitterdog 10.0 but now if i ever
get sued uh i'm just sending them your
way you're my representation at this
point so thank you thanks so much for
joining mark i'll send you my engagement
letter and you can send me a retainer
now that being said i'm not saying that
you should all try to emulate mark
robert's letterboxes here these bait
packages are works of clever engineering
that take great care not to hurt anyone
and since most of you are not former
nasa engineers uh you might screw this
up and as a reminder as always this is
not legal advice i am not your lawyer
and if you get in trouble i am not
coming to court to bail you out again
now that said this video isn't over my
whole interview with mark robert is way
longer and we go into a ton of depth
well literally this year it was like
twice as hard to get a package stolen
we're kind of batmanning our way to like
decreasing porch pirates did you ever
consider something a little stronger
than glitter and fart spray like
explosives or ninja stars or venomous
snakes i want a little bit of
retribution and i want a little bit of
deterrence the whole 20-minute interview
is part of an extended version of this
video over at nebula thanks to today's
sponsor curiosity stream and nebula is
the only way to watch my first
documentary bad law words good it's a
long-form documentary where i talk about
all the most common legal and linguistic
comments that people throw around in
everyday life incorrectly it's a
hilarious romp through legal
misunderstandings logical fallacies and
law and order parodies and it's only on
nebula which you can get for free with
curiosity stream oh and by the way we've
been developing nebula like crazy nebula
now has apps for ios android apple tv
roku fire tv and android tv and all of
my videos are available on curiosity
stream ad-free often with tons and tons
of extra content my fellow creators and
i really care about nebula because it's
a place where we can experiment with
content and put things on there that we
couldn't put on youtube and we're
thrilled to be partnering with
curiositystream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
in long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos you
will love the stuff on curiositystream
and we worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream with the
link in the description you'll also get
a nebulous subscription for free and to
be clear that nebulous subscription is
not a trial it's free for as long as
you're a curiosity stream member and
right now curiosity stream is offering
26 off their annual plans that's less
than 15 for the entire year for both
curiosity stream and nebula so if you
click on the link that's on screen right
now or the link that's below you'll get
curiosity stream and nebula for 26 off
or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly and it's the only way to see my
documentary bad law words good so just
click on the link that's on screen or in
the description plus clicking on that
link really helps out this channel and
while you're there click on this
playlist with all my other real law
reviews so click on this link or i'll
see you in court